hello and welcome to incite Germany my
guest this week is from Cameroon and
came to live here in Germany in 1994 not
really sure of what she wanted to do
professionally today array kono is an
international fashion designer with
their own label and her creations are
sold in 35 countries around the world so
let's find out how she made it in the
cutthroat world of fashion and why she
came here to Germany and stayed welcome
to the program first of all you look
incredibly chic of course is this your
own creation oh yes this mine and this
is mine and these idle or its from some
of the brain yes okay we were missing
any other brand well actually I mean you
obviously like to wear your own design
clothes but you don't wear them all the
time do you have another favorite
designer yeah I do I mean favorite
designer in the sense of I really admire
this designer he's called Nicholas guess
Kira from Balenciaga but I don't buy no
mainstream brands I would prefer to wear
my own design and it's cheaper well
we're gonna see worse during the show
we're gonna see a lot of your designs
during the show but I want to ask you
about coming to Europe will talk about
you come from Cameroon originally yes
when you were 20 you came to Europe yeah
why um actually it's a traditional
traditional if in my family everyone
went to study abroad because I'm
english-speaking cameronian and when I
left Cameron we hardly had any
University's English big universe in
universities so my father my uncle's
everyone went to study abroad they all
went to eat America England oh did both
so I had to go somewhere in Europe and
and I've been in bodies could I spent
half of my life in boarding school and I
was just tired of being with the same
people so I thought um where could I go
away
yeah where no one's going because
everyone went to America England and I
thought Germany would be a cool place
it's a strange reason because people try
to go to different countries because of
the language is easier or they have
family there or then love with somebody
that was my reason why I came to Germany
yeah yeah yeah and but you you came and
studied at various goethe institute yes
yes it was that sort of primary thing to
learn the language first you had to I
had to learn German I mean this was my
first priority because I wanted to study
translation ok nice ok and actually did
mm-hmm yes and you I know you went to
roten Borg of der tauber yes which is I
mean you think it's a movie set don't
you really yeah so what's that it
doesn't look real at all it was amazing
yes like I mean I didn't really know
Germany so I thought this is Germany you
know I thought the whole of Germany
looked like that that was the first
place I went to and I was so fascinated
to know because Germany and Garissa to
just have like amazing service for their
students you know we lived in the hotel
like in hotels they took care of
everything and I remember it was the
first time I saw snow in my life and I
was willing to waited to just cool and I
had their me British girlfriend and she
was walking ahead of me and I saw snow
on her head and I said hey sue you you
hate in washer haze it's the Sun white
stuff on it and she said shut up can't
you see snow and I was so fascinated I
was just like so excited you know this
is funny and from rodenberg on the tower
I think Kim's a or I mean I'm chiemsee
yeah and then Berlin Berlin exactly I'm
why Berlin why did you come to Berlin um
because actually my I wanted originally
I wanted to come directly to Berlin but
I didn't have any no-growth assist was
very popular in those days and I didn't
have a place in blue in Berlin so that's
why I went to Rotenberg first I'm then
to to Priam Kim's
a and they finally had a place in going
to city of building so actually
originally I wanted to come to bed
almost there a special feeling about I
mean you've been here it's thing to know
I was just some it was my just my
instinct you know like just just could
be the most interested city in Germany
cuz everyone was talking about the lame
when I was in school you know when we
did history it was all Germany was just
ballet me now no one talked about born
in the books you know so so I mean this
was somewhere in my memory this was
somewhere my memories I think um I
didn't you know I was young and I just
didn't care i just wanted to go to
ballet man enjoy life ok that's a good
cute time to find out more about ra
Kono's life since she came early Harry
Cano first became inspired by Berlin
shop windows 12 years ago
she originally came to Berlin as an
interpreter and soon fell under the
spell of the German capital her
fascination with the out of the ordinary
and her hard work and stamina made it
possible for cono to establish herself
in the fashion industry which is a tough
go for anyone shop open message I've
been lucky enough to be successful at
what I'm doing maybe it's because I see
the world differently from people who
were born here I can see a completely
different solution to the same problems
I think that's a big advantage cotto is
constantly coming up with new ideas
seeing Germany and its people from an
outsider's point of view gives her the
freedom to go her own white 10 years on
and kono now sells her clothes in 35
countries worldwide and has two
exclusive stores in Berlin she had no
idea she'd stay so long when she first
arrived
luckily caught on never regarded working
around the clock as a chore it's her
passion her aim is simple to make sure
that her clients look better in her
clothes than they did when they came
into her shop the fraud is finally
enough the woman that I have in mind is
tall and blonde with short hair she's a
prima donna she has broad shoulders and
she has proper curbs a real woman
shootin losers and when you look at me
well I'm quite the opposite really
re cano has made good use of her
opportunities and after 22 years of hard
work in Berlin she's built up her own
worldwide fashion emporium
and she's spending a little time with us
here in the studio inside Germany you
said they're seeing Germany is a few
years back admittedly but you said
they're seeing Germany from an
outsider's point of view is a big
advantage um but now you've been here so
long do you still feel an outsider um no
I realized you know sometimes you know
you're not such as we will sometime the
grass is greener where we're not you
know and sometimes you you just like
feel like I would like to be somewhere
else and then I realize whenever I
travel I'm just like happy to go back
home and home is believed mmm so I still
just just I'm just like totally in love
with this city you know and I want to
talk about Germany because I haven't
lived everywhere in Germany I can just
talk before you live down south hey
lived in the south rodenbach of the
tower there was just like months I'm for
you you know so you know and and I felt
like a tourist then you know and premium
Kinzie was just a month or two as well
and Berlin is like I I didn't mention
that but when you first came to Europe
you came to Milan yes fashion capital
yes but you don't like it very much no I
don't like Milan I don't like Milan and
I didn't like Milan there then I'm I I
don't even like meal unless now and
sister um at the beginning I just had a
feeling I couldn't learn anything from
the culture oops sorry it's sorry italy
we don't mind it starts dwt it is just a
fin I mean like you have great artis and
great designers for me to leave it
doesn't feel my have that kind of change
this and and now when I go back to Italy
I get really mad sometimes you know
because I in Milan I can't even get a
taxi from the streets I have to when I
go to work in Milan I take my employees
with me I have to ask my blonde employee
to just stand in front of me to be able
to get a taxi Horatius please yes I'll
get a taste they don't take me and
sometimes I get into the taxi and I ask
the taxi driver you know like what's
your problem and they start telling me
know all this Moroccan
in some still in a man and whatever and
I thought I have to be punished for that
no I when I get some land it's really me
money now because when you go down to
like two florins it's a bit different
and I have fantastic clients in Rome you
know that own stores in Rome I know and
if I go to to to to Sicily it's great
that Milan is just I don't know what's
wrong with that cities just down let's
keep going south yes it won't coach at
cameroon yes and tell me first of all
where where you were born in cameron was
born in a town called limbo today it's
called victoria we got a map that I
think I will today it's called Victor I
thought it's the other way sorry you're
right while school victory victory
today's leaving on Marcus yeah you
forgot I forgot yeah and you did bring I
have to say you bought some of the most
gorgeous pictures this is oh my god
that's me on the left I look like a boy
and this the girl next to me is my
sister yeah and the little boy and the
two girls in the middle our neighbors
and the girl on the right hand side is
my cousin and the man in our house in
the window is my uncle yeah yes and now
I guess this now is this the [ __ ] this
is these are my brothers or sisters and
that's my stepmom you know she was like
she was just you were all this please
say he dresses you know she was I think
she's one of my biggest inspirations as
far as the fabrics I use in my designer
concern you can say that's the police a
dress she wore and she had lots of them
and she was always like really glamorous
and really really dressed up that's my
statement although you came to Europe as
a 20 year old and sort of we're gonna
study German and become a translator
when did the fashion thing do you think
it was always there for me are you sure
I thought my first my first Kurt I was
for only half years old and as a child I
hardly played because i just spent a lot
of time sewing no one understood because
my my pair
we're all lucky academics and my staple
she was the prophet saw my father was an
engineer and they didn't understand why
I just wanted to so I sold for everybody
I sold for my friends I sold for myself
and when I got older if I had a
boyfriend I sold everything with my
hands for them I usually popular with
the boyfriends I'm sure now another me I
always think of fashion designers and
draw these wonderful sketches I believe
you don't draw sketches you work with a
tailor's dummy is that right yes I start
I do it the other way around yeah he's
the most designers did a drawing and
they realize it and I think because I
said it saw in so early and had to do my
own patterns so early I design actually
on the dummy and and I do the sculptures
and then I do the drawing and before
most of the time before i do a drawing
the pieces already completely sewn in my
head so Nigel my collection I just AM
put it together put the pins and take to
the tailor I don't experiment with with
with cotton fabrics like most people do
like do a sample that you cannot use and
then use the real fabric i start with
with the fabric as meant for the
collection but it's not quite difficult
when I mean you've you've got your own
label now you must have other people
making your things for you um I I mean
if you you have to do everything around
the tailor's dummy yourself you can't
have your your seamstresses doing that
for you actually just the samples just
as samples because they can't see what
are MS I want to see and if I do a
drawing and give a seamstress a pattern
maker to do the patent they cannot see
my vision so I eventually do the the the
the pieces myself on the dummy and also
do the patterns because I work with the
spatial fabric that no one is trained to
use when you got to Berlin yes
goethe-institut learning German going to
be a translator
but you've got a fashion label so how
did that all get going I should've been
tricky yeah I eyes for the translation
just to make my parents happy because
they didn't believe in me know we I'm
from Africa we have other problems than
done making people beautiful than making
clothes so they do you understand why my
sister's my sister is a lawyer my
brother Sadako everyone is doctor a
lawyer engineer whatever and they called
me a tailor they said why do you want to
be a Taylor and I couldn't give right
here it was def different presumably
here yes any and you started what did
you do to get me hear your Europe your
own fashion label I want to know by my
god that's amore because I worked for
for for always worked for fashion brands
so the I work for a textile designer but
she also had brand and and I work for
her in her stall as a salesperson and
five days a week or six days a week and
when she had pieces that she couldn't
sell for like three four five six years
it took them to the markets for her and
sell them I saw them at the monitor the
markets you started yes you say so I'm
gonna gave you as it's a long story and
we're going to cut to showing some of
your fashion now we've got some pictures
from what was called african fashion day
at the Berlin Fashion Week first of all
why do we have an african fashion day at
the berlin fashion do you think um
honestly i don't know i was just happy
to be here and to be in berlin and my
girlfriend I Wilma Obama she's a patron
of the african fashion day and Sean
Obama sis exactly is she asked me and
she said I'm gonna be the patron of of
the african fashion day do you want to
join Julie to the show I'm I said I feel
part of it and I'd like to I didn't
really know what was all about you know
but she was very optimistic about it I'm
really really a big motivation for me
well it was slightly
loaded question in that for me I have no
idea about fashion I'm a man no but I
but to me this seems to be these big
fashion houses that I'm not going to
name there's often a lot of African
influences yeah but I only know of one
if you like famous African fashion
designer of African sent really fair
ozwald boateng in England I mean why do
you think there's so much infants but I
don't see designers coming out of Africa
itself um it's difficult to explain
because the the market is a problem
because the the big I think the big
designers are using the big brands are
using the the influence they 222222 I
think there's no market the market is
very small you know and if you look if
you look at people in the streets in
Europe you don't see people wearing the
colorful fabrics you know we have from
Africa I think that's where the problem
is coming from no okay what do you think
about Berlin as a becoming a fashion
capital is it becoming what I mean when
you started there was fashioned wasn't a
big thing in Berlin but its enormous a
man yes it's you've been here yes so has
it reached its peak and no is nowhere
close to pick it's really really far
away from what's going on in Paris or
Milan do you think it will get that far
these I can't answer this question
because um because my experience is I
show my collection in Milan I show in
London as showing the sort of and
assuring Paris and my biggest fashion
market is is the Arab world you know and
and on Americans as well and when I try
to get my customers to come to Berlin
they're not coming so um I don't know
why um when I show in berlin you know i
sell i do more business in paris i do my
business in London
my business is to sort of an Milan and
the only place where I really do
business in the lane is in my store in
the hakushaku felt otherwise some
interest it's a um I think it's gonna
come the business side is going to come
you know lots of people are coming here
to party but let me see participation so
they think the the fashion the fashion
scene in Berlin has to get more serious
you know because fashion is not a party
is a business ya know and this is some
problem in Berlin ok my guest is
berlin-based fashion designer re corner
and just the other day she moved
apartments and invite us along to the
new one but first a coffee in her
favorite cafe don't including to do you
think you think you think you do don't
you don't you don't you do it's like
really great to walk in here and I'm
have a big smile for making you know
she's like always really happy to see me
the coffee is really tasting and say
really and being rude and it's a great
atmosphere to be 22 22 I came here and
make me here and I thought it's mr.
women's business I'm always like if I
see anything that's run by women I
always want to go and put the money
there
I just walked into this wonderful place
two days ago I live here with my son
Aaron and my auntie momma Lucy most of
the time always lived in places which
always found the reason not to like I
think it's just typical in Berlin you
know that we move so often and I just
hope I find some peace here I feel like
you know as an artist and I really have
a really difficult job and to get away
from the city and just be quiet you know
it's like really yeah it feels like a
holiday this dress is a dress I'm like
saving if if so if I will be asked you
know to to get married it's what I love
the way you know maybe I change my mind
but I'm saying the dress just for this
event you know to wake up in the morning
and look in water look in a lake in a
second when it's at begin my day in a
wonderful way nature is just an amazing
inspiration and for me I don't really
need to travel around the world to do to
get inspired by different colors just
sitting here you know and I'm watching
the water and seeing the trees move and
I'm always amazed you know how much you
know how much information how much stuff
and how much creative input you can get
you
and you may have noticed in that report
this portrait of RA it was slightly
smaller this I have to say as the
original it's a photograph which has
been pixelated yeah yeah and we're going
to get a smaller copy signed by our
guests to give away and just write to us
at the usual address that's in sight at
DW de you can also drop us a line about
anything you like to do with the show of
course we love to have praise but we
reluctantly accept criticism as well now
I don't know whether anybody noticed in
that report but you were talking in your
kitchen and your son came past and took
the cloth from your aunt and started
polishing the glass and I want to know
on a personal level how did you manage
to get a 12 year old boy to do that his
his his just I mean it's not because
it's my son he's just amazing you know
he just spends muslim just his time
trying to make mom happy and yes he's
he's just so special and I really
sometimes wonder you know like where
that's coming from really how do you
actually makes running an international
business and bringing up a son at the
same time it must be told and discipline
had work and it strong will ya know and
to win the race well great respect no
you also i heard we didn't see it in the
report where you have two kitchens one
for African cooking for German cooking
tell us about that um yeah because we
you know what I'm African and cooking is
you have like knots very strong spices
you know and we use like smoke Browns we
used like lots of knots and really
really do stink or smell and and I love
it when the food is done but when it's
been cooked you know sometimes a bit
irritating so prepare to have you know
the little kitchen and on the side what
do you think
of german food I live lyst you know I
mean I decided to become a vegetarian
but I still love lists and no be a [ __ ]
a bit of a problem nice problem whenever
I go by Cory Voss stand you know I'm
like oh I'd love to have in Berlin like
a break i love i love bavarian food as
well yeah like yeah I love bavarian food
we saw your that also there with a
wedding dress or a potential of a
beautiful dress you put in your
questionnaire that we send out don't
worry that you think German men are
handsome yes you are you are you waiting
for a hater German man kalanoro last
tree yeah yeah what is it about German
bed that you particularly like um I'm
Germans this one and characteristics
that people don't see in Germans Germans
are like hard on the outside and soft on
the inside you know and this alike and
and they come across as cold and
distance and and I mean as i said i love
Berlin you know because people are
really nice and really friendly but it
takes the time you mean it takes time
takes time takes time to make
friendships is that what you say mmm not
in Berlin no not in Berlin I would say
so not in Berlin and sort of hard on the
outside soft on the inside that that
makes a good partner yeah yeah would you
live elsewhere in Germany um um maybe
handbook but it's too rainy you know and
I love the freedom in Berlin I love this
artistic side lady no I love the fact
that there's always something going on
and you can choose you know every day of
the week can choose to to do something
really amazing and something really
great and and I mean because of my job
there's no reason for me to go to
Hamburg you know Berlin is a place where
fashion is trying to get into and and
I'm just happy to be part of it has it
taken out I mean Dusseldorf when I came
to Germany 28
Dorf was the sort of fashion there isn't
a fashion capital in but dussel door was
the place for fashion there's Berlin
really taken over from that now or is
there a difference I not really taking
over because and I think m and the sort
of missed out something and the stuff
just hold off underestimated the
glamorous side of fashion do you use
this you know it was it was just
business and being dusted off and it's
still a little bit but Berlin you know
use the advantage you know as a capital
T 2 and the party city and most of the
famous people in Germany live in Berlin
I'm not in Dusseldorf and they use these
red carpets effect you know sinisterly
no glamorous here are kind of phenomena
in LA in a Berlin way yeah yeah yeah you
know no it's um is for example he's very
chic had to be poor in Berlin you know
that yeah yeah it's very chic to be poor
in Berlin denise is very shaky to walk
around looking scruffy yeah than the
other way around yeah there's this
saying isn't it from the man Vernon who
says poor butt sex exactly in Berlin
yeah now a couple more pictures a
picture now oh my god this is this your
time that's my dad in Wisconsin he
studied in Wisconsin the 60s and lived
to this family you know and it's a mazal
family because behind the picture it's
written that this was seized his his
family but when they went to church the
way they were at the front and he will
had like at least five benches in
between him and the rest of the church
really yes but the family themselves
weren't like that the world like that
you can see on the picture yeah you know
it took him like their child but when
the left they hurt their home it was
another story I'm is this that's me yeah
it looks like a boy you always say you
look like a boy you're very feminine
I mean the pictures that look like a boy
bees and that's my dad on the left hand
side and his friends hmm 12 his daughter
and a pram and you went abroad to study
your your brother sisters whenever I
mean this is huge cost to your family
and stuff oh is it just one thing they
really wanted to do yeah it was
tradition you know and we all went to
pray I mean we all went to private
schools in Cameroon you know we for my
father education was very very important
and he spent all his money I know not
all his money spent and everything he
could on our education this was very I
believe all your family have left
cameroon there now why is that I mean
why you you have been back for a long
time yes I haven't been back because my
father died I mean it's a sad story he
died many years ago and didn't leave a
will so and left like seven houses and
I'm scared to get cured oh if I go back
yeah I'm scared I mean this is the
reason why I didn't go back home for so
many years since he died because people
are living in this house is full without
paying rent and I tried to go and I
tried to go like three years ago to show
my son where I'm coming from and someone
found out and I received an anonymous a
horrible and on the most later you know
like retreating in my life and and the
life of my child so I didn't go back so
this is that's very sad it's very sad
you know because he didn't build those
houses and for this to happen no yeah
yeah but you're happy here in Germany
yeah fond of home found a new home yeah
how was it I want to ask you about as a
woman setting up a business here was it
was that easy I never saw my service a
woman I mean I'm not transsexual oh oh
man keep saying every photo you see you
look like a boy no never
never saw myself as a woman I am having
this any disadvantages you know I just
went for for what I could get you know I
just worked as hard as I could of course
I was lucky you know because as I told
you before I I started selling my stuff
at the markets my my clothing at the
market because I mean I didn't have my
parent my father died years ago and it
didn't occur to me to go to a bank they
wouldn't have given given me any money
anyway so i started the market and got
very lucky that a woman found me and she
saw my clothing and she was like what
are you doing here with so much talent
and she got the context for me in west
germany to start selling my my
collection in different stores in west
germany and that's how I was able to
leave the market so my story is not just
about been lucky in just about hard work
I've been very lucky in in Germany and
you know people have been really really
kind to me know how I show her face like
a great address you know it's this this
is in the middle of Berlin I should
explain this is a very cool address you
know when I applied to get this tour
doing lots and lots of applications you
know from lots of people and they the
the the the owners you know this they
told me know when we saw you we thought
you're the one who has to get this place
you know and so I can't complain about
why do you think that wow um they saw of
course is so talent and the so talent I
think and and I think I was just lucky
again yeah yes because that's where I've
said no we don't want you you know we
want this or this designer and yeah ok
now you most probably don't associate
Germany with some sea and sand but there
is some beautiful coastline up on the
Baltic Sea and this is where one of our
a corners favorite sponsors
Reuben is germany's largest island but
wherever you happen to be on Rugen
you're never more than seven kilometers
from the coast
Vince is the islands most popular resort
more than a million vacationers from
Germany and abroad visit rugen every
year oh my gosh why it's I'm from
Switzerland and he wanted to show me the
island island I love being beside to see
the Baltic has a really magical
attraction mahjong that's what miss one
day here in Vince's like a whole week of
vacation I talk you in Vince originally
a small fishing village Vince became a
tourist destination in 1876 when the
first hotel was built the turn of the
19th to the 20th century saw the rise of
a distinctive architectural style
comment North German resorts it
incorporated ornate balconies windows
and arches today many of the villas have
been divided up into vacation apartments
Rogan is perhaps most famous for its
chalk cliffs which inspired the German
Romantic artists Caspar David Friedrich
back in 1818 when he was there on his
honeymoon
the COO next rule is still the islands
best known landmark the four kilometer
long Rugen bridge takes you to the
mainland and to the city of straw zones
recent additions to the skyline
contrasts sharply with the centuries-old
brick gothic constructions the Old Town
Hall is a notable example
the entire old city is a unesco world
cultural heritage site and install zones
you'll find a true Baltic tradition
Henry Rasmus is the only person still
preparing the world-famous bismarck
herring in accordance with the original
recipe from 1871 it was mocking it gets
its name from otto von bismarck Johann
Vic man invented this method of
preparation install zones as a devoted
follower of Bismarck he sent the
Chancellor cake and Bismack thanked him
by allowing the product to carry his
name Bismarck isn't the only statesman
to have tried the marinated fish other
politicians have sampled the tangy
delicacy to and the best way to enjoy it
is with a view of the island of rügen my
guest is fashion designer Erik or no who
likes the island of rügen I love for the
sun sea and the sand or for other
reasons sorry for the sun sea and sand
or for other reasons it's really you can
really be quiet and Reagan you know I
love to go to eat hidden say there's an
island next to reading which is called
part of their little ones well he didn't
say I'm there there no cows you know
just go on your bike and and you can
really really really like relax and this
is ray mmm yeah that's true but it was
good to show that cuz people don't think
Germany has coast yeah it's a beautiful
cause um we are also noticed in the
Bismarck herrings I'm not going to ask
you about biz not having but about the
man because in our questionnaire the you
said you were a great adma you were a
great admirer of otto von bismarck why
um because of what he did for Germany
and I thought it was just like really
amazing and what he he achieved you know
the franco-prussian war and the
reunification of Germany in the 19th
century but you know this high opinion
of him I
I just had to like three weeks ago
because seems to excite started reading
his love letters between him and his
wife and I was sure to see that he
wasn't liberal at all he was
anti-semitic and he was really really
arrogant and this was quite
disappointing no you read a lot of
historical stuff oh yeah I love our
years I love I'm history even when I
read books you know just for fun the
most there must be something historical
you know involved in the stories okay
yeah many people I read a lot of
literature I prefer history yes do you
read in German Julie jariabek surgery
did i read in German I read in Italian i
read in French I read in English I
ridden all the languages they speak here
Wow yes there was also in that report a
very short picture of angular Merkel
with George W Bush you put down in our
questionnaire that angle America's your
favorite german but you wouldn't vote
for her I wouldn't vote her party if you
didn't have a part of behind hold water
but I'm not German anyway so so I can't
and I don't have a German passport I'm
Italian your Italian is yeah but would
you like to have a German possible no
I'm not really interests I'm not really
keen you know I mean having any talent /
sport is just same as having a German
one it's too much hassle that means you
know I mean you said early in the pro
you weren't particularly fond of certain
bits of Italy and but you don't want
you're so fond of Germany and think yes
this is my home I mean your favorite
music Oh says favorite song you like
Ramstein say I don't have to explain
them raw oysters I love you know they're
like the the big German artists know
like Magna and
no all the big ones but you know when it
comes to like rock and roll I love
Rammstein I think it's very all the rock
and roll you know heavy metal yes raise
more the broker role is quite loud but
the one that really intrigued me is when
we we asked people to name their
favorite german words you can think of
one but you talked about the language
and you said the language is very
glamorous and elegant now I have to say
and I don't want to denigrate language
in any way it's a wonderful language but
I've never heard the adjutant's use
elegant and glamorous to me German
sounds really really beautiful
especially the German you speak in
handbook i think is very very very very
very glamorous language to me german is
to me is like exactly the opposite of
Spanish you know for example i don't
like spanish i don't like the sounds you
know and yeah it sounds primitive to me
as a language it's interesting because
of course musically of course Germany in
wonderful music nation and of course
they wrote all the operas and things
were some of the word written in Italian
but you know there's lots of stuff
remotes out there's lots of study I mean
I thinking of Strauss I'm thinking of
them schubert and Schumann all these
wonderful songs written in German of
course so its your right to say that
elegant and very do you remember what
you put down for the best kept secret in
Germany I'll tell you I'll just start
you off but it's not it's it's not
racist who is and yeah it's um it's I
mean it's I can only talk about my
experience I know there are lots of
people having in races experiences in
Germany I wouldn't you know I don't have
to hurry you cuz we're young but I never
looked for flats or looked for a job and
I never
and look was looking for a flat or but
trying to get a job I didn't get in
Germany and I travel a lot in in a
traveling lot because of my job I go to
I'm very really awful in Paris and I
find a French very racist and in Italy
you know I wouldn't even get a taxi on
the streets in Italy this is quite a
little i mentioned this and i don't have
this experiences in Germany you know
like the floods I moved into now it's
really really amazing flat you know and
I saw it and I was like maybe I am gonna
take it maybe not and I'm the owner she
called me and she said there are lots of
people interested in this for in this
flat but I want to give it to you and I
said okay the Lord have it is a
wonderful way to array Connor top
fashion designer selling in 35 countries
hope you make it in many more countries
but do stay here in Germany with us it
sounds as though you're going to thanks
very much for being with us today and
thank you very much watching the show
don't forget the address to write into
his insight at BW de that's it for this
week join us again at the same time next
week bye bye for now
you